we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
i can't tell fully if this voicemail
is anti-transgender or sort of neutral
or what the caller is exactly talking
about so i want to play it
and listen to it together with you let's
see if we can figure this out
hi david my name is ashley um i wanted
to talk about the
transgenders i think it doesn't take a
genius
to realize that when you put a bunch of
people who are from
different backgrounds and different
ethnicities together
you're going to end up with some people
that are kind of confusing
so i'm i'm noticing the constant up
speak that's not really bothering me
it's more you know the transgenders
it's already kind of weird i don't
necessarily think it's about gender i
just think it's like
you just have different looking people
that you're not used to seeing
and i guess this draws like a lot of
conclusions but i don't think
i don't think it takes a genius to
figure out that
when you're born a woman with a vagina
that means you're a woman for life and
that when you're a
man when you're born with a penis
you're a dude for life i don't think it
takes a genius
okay so it's seeming anti-trans right to
figure that out
and if there's some weird complications
it's probably because of the cultural
difference
and i just think this is completely what
what does comp what does complication
mean i don't even know what th what
they're saying
well [ __ ] and these people are really
ignorant
which people that's a weird voicemail
right
help me parse that out and figure out
what what it's all about i don't really
i don't really understand what that's
what's going on there
we have a great it doesn't sound good
though let me put it that way it doesn't
sound particularly enlightened or
sensitive
um we have a great bonus show for you
today we will be talking about the
america first caucus which lasted one
day
[Laughter]
it involves marjorie taylor green and it
lasted one day
massachusetts also doing some very
interesting new climate law
that if it all goes as planned
we'll zero out carbon pollution for the
state
very very aggressive and forward-looking
and we will also look at what seems to
be uh senate democrats
settling on a 25 corporate tax rate for
joe biden's
changes to the tax plan remember it was
35
previously trump dropped it to 21. joe
biden was looking at raising to 28
and it looks as though senate democrats
are okay with 25 what i want to talk
about is whether this even matters
and some of you who have heard me talk
about the corporate tax rate before
probably already know
where where i'm going that's on today's
bonus show okay get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at
joinpacman.com we have a coupon code the
coupon code is
better21 and very exciting
follow me on bitcloud i
rarely am excited about new platforms
i'm very excited about this one i spent
the weekend
checking it out uh go to davidpakman.com
bitclout b-i-t-c-l-o-u-t
follow me there at minimum check out how
it works
i'll have more about it later in the
week